well now from Halloween haunts to drinks
let's check in with liquor lineup the
sponsors of this segment to learn about
a different way to tap into the spirits
Welcome to our shop I'm Solomon Mo what
do we have for our liquor lineup today
today we're having a blood orange scary
Margarita first we're going to start
with our tequila Ocho two ounces
tequila Ocho is a small batch of tequila
we specialize in small batch limited
edition Tequilas and whiskeys go to our
website liquorlineup.com and you can
order this tequila next we have one
ounce of Cointreau
[Music]
two ounces of blood orange just for the
flavor
[Music]
and then finally we top it off with just
two ounces of lime juice all of these
ingredients can be found on our app
download our app liquor lineup from the
App Store and we deliver daily
shake a little bit so we can mix them
together
pour straight
[Applause]
and then finally we garnish it with our
burnt orange for a little bit of zest
and a little bit of extra taste please
enjoy I'm excited about this one
[Music]
definitely delicious I get that zest
definitely a holiday cocktail get this
one for your home enjoy happy Halloween
thank you to liquor lineup for
sponsoring this segment they are located
on North Decatur Boulevard in North Las
Vegas for more information you can call
702-616-0311 you can also visit
liquorlinup.com to make it all easier
for you you can also scan that QR code
right there on your screen